وتابع في تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
حيث اعلنت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ان
القوات الروسيه تواصل تركيز جهودها
الرئيسيه على اتجاهات ليمن وبخمت ومارينكا
مشيره الى استمرار القتال العنيف في تلك
المناطق
ار كاذ قالت الاداره العسكريه الاوكرانيه
ان ثلاثه اشخاص قتلوا في قصر روسي
بالصواريخ على بلده فوفشان بمنطقه
قالت مراسله الجزيره ان القوات الاوكرانيه
قصفت احياء سكنيه في المدينه بعشرات
القذائف منذ ساعات الصباح
وصف مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني ميخائيل
بودولياك الهجوم الروسيه على كراماتورس
بالعمل الارهابي الذي يهدف لترويع
المدنيين وقال بودياك للجزيره ان القصف
استهدف مكانا مقتضا بالمدنيين ولا علاقه
له باي اغراض عسكريه جاته طالب الرئيس
البولندي النيتو بما سماه اليقظه ازاء نقل
مقاتلي فاجنر الى بيلاروسيا ينضم الينا من
كييف مراسل جزيره عمر الحاج عمر ضعنا في
سياق هذه التصريحات السياسيه خاصه قلق
جيران اكياز من نقل مقاتلي فاغنر الى
بيلاروسيا
نعم جلال رئيس الوزراء البولندي اندري
دوده وصل اليوم عند الظهيره والتقى
الرئيسكي ومستشاريه وعبر بالفعل عن هذا
القلق بالانتقالي قائد قوات
الى بيلاروسيا وقال ان اوروبا اوروبا وحلف
الناتو لابد ان يكونوا متيقظين لهذا
الاجراء اشار ايضا الى هذا التهديد الكبير
الذي وصفه
كبير حسب وصفه الى ما يحدث في محطه
التي قالت تقارير استخباراتيه اوكرانيه ان
القوات الروسيه وضعت خطه لاحداث كما سماها
عمل ارهابي في تلك المنطقه وبالتالي هذا
الانفجار سيؤدي الى انتشار اشعاعات نوويه
ليس فقط في اوكرانيا فقط بل الى جيرانها
ومناطق اخرى وقال ان علينا ان نضع بالحسبه
نضعه بالحسبان كل الاحتمالات لمواجهته مثل
هذا الحدث اشار ايضا الى حث
لضمه اوكرانيا بشكل نهائي الى حلف شمال
الاطلسي وهذه الجهود تاتي كلها السباقا
لقمه الحلف التي ستكون في جولاي تموز
المقبل ايضا كان هناك زياره للرئيس
الليتواني والذي التقى الرئيس ذانيسكي
كذلك الامر ومستشاري نفسه كان له حديث
اليوم في مجلس النواب
اليوم وتحدث عن اهميه وضع الاخطاء الاهداف
الاساسيه للحرب هنا وهي تحرير الاراضي
الاوكرانيه به اليوم كان لنا حديث مع
مستشار الاعلامي للرئيس زينسكي تحدث عن
كثير من المواضيع واشار الى ما سماه
بالهجوم الارهابي الذي وقع فيه
عدد من المدنيين لنستمع الى ما قال
ما حدث في كراماتورسك ليس جديدا على الروس
فروسيا تفعل ذلك كل يوم خصوصا في المدن
القريبه من الجبهه روسيا تستخدم الاسلحه
الباليستيه وهذه المره نتحدث عن صواريخ اس
300 لقد تعمدوا قصف مكان مقتض بالمدنيين
ولا علاقه له باي اغراض عسكريه الهدف هو
نشر الدعر والتاثير على الحاله النفسيه
للناس